das ist ein wahnsinns rekord 1 641
quadratmeter großes und zweistöckiges
haus wurde tatsächlich zum größten teil
von einem 3d drucker gedruckt kaum
vorstellbar aber die bauzeit dieses
riesigen projekts liegt bei lediglich 17
tagen und auch die kosten sind
vergleichsweise gering und es gibt sogar
gebäude aus dem 3d druckern mit noch
mehr stockwerken ist das also die
zukunft des bauens kriegs um science
fiction die gibt's eigentlich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen es ist weltweit das größte
jemals mit einem 3d drucker gebaute haus
der welt das gebäude ist zweistöckig und
hat eine fläche von 641 quadratmetern
sein standort dubai in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten hier ist es tagsüber
sehr heiß und nachts kühlt es sehr stark
ab und diese extremen bedingungen
machten die bauarbeiten nicht gerade
einfach auch die baumaterialien müssen
diesen temperaturschwankungen erst
einmal stand halten
doch das projekt verlief erfolgreich und
das haus ist nun fertiggestellt und das
in einer super kurzen bauzeit konkret
waren es 17 tage also wirklich kaum
vorstellbar
die meisten einzelteile des gebäudes
stammen aus einem 3d drucker und zwar
von dem us-unternehmen abriss chor
diese firma ist spezialisiert auf den
drei den druck im bereich bau und die
arbeiten waren teilweise wirklich
spektakulär denn der drucker musste
zeitweise an einen kran montiert werden
eine spezielle gips art wird hier als
material verwendet diese mischung
besteht aus recyceltem schubs zement und
anderen bestandteilen die dafür sorgen
dass diese mischung schnell trocknet
fertigteile aus beton wurden als
fundament genutzt darauf kamen dann wohl
wende die aus dem 3d drucker stammen
nachdem die wände des erdgeschosses
fertiggestellt wurden kamen die decke
dann wurden die fenster ausgeschnitten
und das ist dem material eingebracht
erst dann folgte das zweite stockwerk
heißt also im klartext der 3d drucker
kümmert sich schicht für schicht um die
grundstruktur dach und fenster wurden
auf konventionelle art und weise
hergestellt und eingesetzt ebenso auch
einige stützkonstruktionen auftraggebern
des ganzen projekts ist übrigens die
stadt dubai mittlerweile ist auch schon
die verwaltung von dubai in das gebäude
eingezogen und hat ihre arbeit
aufgenommen
den mitarbeiter innen kommt jetzt die
weiße außenseite des gebäudes zu gute
dafür sorgt dass es sich innen nicht so
stark aufheizt auch das baumaterial
trägt dazu bei dass die hitze aus den
innenräumen herausgehalten wird dennoch
an dem ganzen prozess waren deutlich
weniger bauarbeiter innen beteiligt als
für den bau eines konventionellen
gebäudes benötigt werden um etwa 70
prozent könnte sich der arbeitsaufwand
durch den einsatz von 3d druckern in der
baubranche reduzieren somit halten sich
auch die kosten in grenzen schätzungen
zufolge könnten diese sogar um etwa 90
prozent sinkt 90 prozent die vision des
unternehmens ups chor ist groß so sind
nicht nur weitere gebäude aus dem 3d
drucker in den usa geplant schon in
naher zukunft soll es ein haus aus dem
3d drucker geben dass innerhalb von
achtung 24 stunden ausgedruckt ist die
angepeilte größe des gebäudes 46
quadratmeter die bauindustrie vor allem
in dubai selbst ist jedenfalls angefixt
von der technik dazu time orkan von
einer immobilienagentur vor ort der
bedarf an bezahlbaren gebäuden in dubai
ist viel größer geworden wenn sich also
eine industrie entwickelt die einheiten
zu billigeren konditionen herstellen
kann weil sie viel weniger arbeitskraft
bezahlen muss dann würden auch die
preise für das endprodukt deutlich
sinken
doch um das ganze möglich massentauglich
zu machen müssen sich die gebäude dieser
art erst einmal beweisen können sie
umwelt- und wettereinflüssen trotzen und
trotzen sie auch mögliche
naturkatastrophen die vereinigten
arabischen emirate jedenfalls sehen sie
schon als zentrum der 3d bauindustrie
dabei ist das gebäude in dubai längst
nicht das erste dieser art es gibt sogar
welche die deutlich höher sind zum
beispiel das 27 meter hohe gebäude im
chinesischen suzhou das sogar fünf
stockwerke umfasst und ebenfalls aus dem
3d drucker stammt hierbei handelt es
sich weltweit also um das höchste
gebäude aus dem 3d drucker das nun
fertiggestellte haus in dubai aber hat
die weltweit größte quadratmeterzahl und
bereits ist damit bereits ins buch der
rekorde eingetragen kunst organe aus dem
3d drucker kunst vanina erfolgreich
implantiert ja das gibt es auch und zwar
hier bei pixum science fiction also
anklicken anschauen und abo oder kanal
mitglied werden denn dann bekommt ihr
die videos nämlich vor allen anderen
viel früher direkt wenn sie hochgeladen
werden wir könnten sofort kommentieren
leiten nur leicht am besten und die
unterstützt uns dabei dass hier möglich
zu
machen also klicks um science-fiction
den kanal mit den täglichen
wissenschafts videos die übrigens alle
von wissenschaftsjournalisten
recherchiert und geschrieben werden bis
dann bleibt dran